you are now thinking about dr. Strange's
naked butt benedict cumberbatch hello
lad Bible I've traveled to the deepest
darkest corners of the internet to pick
through some beautiful pieces of
fanfiction about myself and the
character I played in Avengers Doctor
Strange so that's yeah that's happening
showing one day dr. strange was crying
in his shower because he just saw the
season premiere of My Little Pony
Friendship is Magic he cried because he
wanted chrysalis to be good but she was
like nah then all of a sudden his phone
rang he got up out of the shower and his
steaming hot body melted the mirror by
accident that he sniffle then tried to
pick up the phone but he didn't realize
his hands were still wet so it slipped
right out of his fingers and fell on the
floor of course it was an iPhone so the
screen was obliterated and he had to use
the iveco motor to reverse time and make
ice cream brand new like he does every
time he breaks anything ever except our
heart sniffle he answered the call ha ha
ha ha ha hello
he asked trying to hold back the tears
strange strange is that new the British
voice asks it was thought apparently
yeah man who else would it be strange he
yelled back at him don't you back sass
me boy I will kick your ass guard Thor
hollered into the phone now I know you
think why is Thor talking on a cell
phone
well my dear children I will never
answer that why did you ever want anyway
strange ask calmly and politely
CAPITAL LETTERS has he rammed his fist
into his wall I wanted you to know Thor
asked if you thought asked still watered
thought also asked to come over and hang
out maybe no strange hung up the time he
then tried to walk back into his
bathroom but he slipped and broke 47
ribs I heard that many he was overacting
actually all he did was land on his
naked butt you are now thinking about
dr. strangers naked but then out of
freaking nowhere Jack Black burst
through his glass window and stretched
out his hand
dude you gotta come with me wait why are
you naked
strange ran away then came back only two
seconds later wearing his super suit his
cloak floating behind him muttering
what do you need jack black strange
asked ready to kick some bootay
there's a giant guy who watched it the
universe Jack yelled he then hopped on
his magic floating guitar and most
impress strains to get on and motioning
for you to get on wait what a giant guy
did he happen to say his name
strange asked dramatic pause for page 10
sympathy yeah I think he said I am yo
mama or something like that Jack said yo
mama Oh God Dormammu strange hopped on
the guitar and they flew away to be
continued
[Music]
thank you lad Bible for giving me the
opportunity to read this beautiful piece
of fanfiction and I hope you liked it as
much as I did brother